two-minute warning before the briefing
begins
[Music]
hello everyone sorry we're a little late
today as you know the president had two
events this morning so we didn't want
our own precedent and transparency to
get in the way of lunch so we're glad
that you all had a few moments there to
eat so our delay was hopefully useful
and helpful to you guys I have an
announcement on the Trump
administration's unwavering support for
our farmers today Secretary of
Agriculture sonny Perdue and senior
adviser Ivanka Trump announced the
launch of the farmers to families food
box program this is a three billion
dollar program to support farmers and
provide food to our most vulnerable
communities senior advisor Ivanka Trump
and secretary Purdue at Purdue are doing
very good work now I would like to focus
on the Trump administration's
unprecedented coronavirus response some
have erroneously suggested that the
Trump administration throughout the
pandemic response PlayBook left by the
obama-biden administration what the
critics failed to note however is that
this thin packet of paper was replaced
by too detailed robust pandemic response
reports commissioned by the Trump
administration so we exchanged this one
which I will hand over to my assistant
Wendy for these two pandemic response
plans in 2018 the Trump administration
issued our pandemic crisis action plan
one of the binders that I just handed to
Lyndee further from August 13th to the
16th the Trump administration conducted
the crimson contagion 20-19 functional
exercise this was a pandemic stimulation
to test the nation's ability to respond
to a large-scale outbreak in January of
2020 HHS issued the crimson contagion
20-19 functional exercise after-action
report that was one of the additional
documents that I just handed over this
exercise expounded upon exposed rather
the shortcomings and legacy planning
documents which inform president Trump's
coronavirus response beginning as early
as January and those legacy planning
document shortcomings were in fact the
papers that I just
/ that were provided to us by the
obama-biden administration for example
president Trump's Crimson after-action
report highlighted that the Obama era
policy directive from November 2016
quote and including from the document
does not provide the reckless and
requisite mechanisms or processes to
effectively leave the coordination of
the federal government's response
instead president Trump established the
white house coronavirus task force and
put vice-president pence in charge of
the interagency response these were
effective decisions and they undoubtedly
enhanced our response to the coronavirus
furthermore what crimson contagion
taught us is that President Trump was
right all along about misguided economic
and trade policies that left Americans
vulnerable to pandemics in June 2016 so
many many years ago then businessman
Donald Trump said this quote America
became the world's dominant economy by
becoming the world's dominant producer I
have visited cities and towns across
this country where a third or even half
of manufacturing jobs have been wiped
out in the last 20 years
today we import nearly 800 billion more
in goods than we export this is not some
natural disaster it is politician made
disaster that was then Canada Trump who
has now implemented those policies as
president Trump and this forward
thinking vision contrasted with that of
President Obama who said quote Trump
just says well I'm going to negotiate a
better deal
well what how exactly are you going to
negotiate that what magic wand do you
have that magic wand was ripping up the
the trans-pacific partnership it was
ripping up NAFTA it was replacing it
with the US Mexico Canada agreement a
great deal for our automakers in our
farmers and it was ending China's
predatory trade policies and negotiating
a historic phase one China deal that is
what this president has done yesterday
President Trump went to Allentown
Pennsylvania and visited Owens and miner
Inc this was a clear example of domestic
manufacturing at work you saw this
administration taking action to
restructure and secure our stockpile of
medical supplies President Trump
released a plan to restructure the
strategic national stock
yesterday and he signed an executive
order providing the authority to ensure
America is producing critical goods
necessary to build up our strategic
stockpiles the president's trip was an
example of what he's been saying all
along that America must manufacture that
America must produce here in our
interior additionally the president
launched project air bridge to bring
supplies from all over the world to
support America's frontline health care
workers the administration partnered
with the private sector to secure
donations and production of PPE and
other medical supplies and president
Trump effectively leveraged the defense
production Act otherwise known as the
DPA to mobilize our country to
manufacture and secure massive amounts
of PPE and ventilators through project
air bridge to date more than 1.4 million
in 95 respirators have been delivered as
well as ninety to nine hundred twenty 1
million glove 17.1 million surgical
gowns and more the Trump PlayBook in the
whole of America response to this
pandemic has far exceeded what this
administration inherited and finally
President Trump took action before the
pandemic to anticipate in game plan such
scenarios president Trump's streamlined
the National Security Council in 2018 by
creating a counter proliferation and bio
defense directorates this director at
combined NSC experts focused on
biological threats under a single and
more senior leader and did away with a
confusing organizational chart that
required some experts to report to two
bosses simultaneously and short the NSC
retain the same number of experts
focused on biological threats that the
Obama administration had but hone them
in and focus them more and house them in
a more coherent structure and with a
more senior leader I'd also note that
this Directorate which exists today is
the same office that critics alleged to
this day that President Trump eliminated
I hope in your reporting you are now
able to debunk this claim recognizing
the seriousness of biological threats
President Trump released a series of
strategic documents to transform our
preparedness for Biological incidents
including pandemics in September of 2018
President Trump released the National
bio defense strategy in May of 2019 he
released the global health security
strategy and in September of 2019 he
signed an EO to modernize and
ruins of vaccines his leadership is
evidence in the early days of this
pandemic and in the preparation before
that and these actions I've outlined
today these plans I noted on helped us
as we approached what it was an
unprecedented crisis it helped us to
deploy our resources and to deliver what
I believe is the one of the best
responses we've seen in this country's
history and with that I'll take
questions
John you talked about Crimson contagion
back in August did that exercise suggest
that early and extensive testing would
be critical in response to any pandemic
I'm not aware of exactly what it
revealed with regard to testing what it
basically did was say to us look some of
the previous iterations of plans have
put HHS in the lead HHS of course plays
a critical role in our response but one
of the things that was identified as you
need a whole-of-government response
that's orchestrated from the highest
levels and for us what that meant in
real time was president Trump
immediately saying hey we need a task
force we need the vice president leading
this we need the White House at the helm
coordinating agencies and that valuable
piece of advice that we garnered from
from from the exercise was able to be
deployed in real time so it was a
valuable exercise that we did in August
of 2019 and going forward well early and
extensive testing now be among the
recommendations that are put into any
future plans so we don't we have not
outlined a future plan just yet we're
still operating off of the one that was
issued fairly recently in January of
2020 I think it's safe to say that you
know we've learned a lot as we've moved
forward and navigated this pandemic then
and navigated the deploying of more than
90 million and 95 respirators a billion
gloves I'm this really historic response
I think we've learned that working with
the private sector has been very
effective we have an incredible
innovative private sector in this
country and to have a businessman at the
helm and president Trump who was able to
coordinate that was very effective and I
think will become the playbook for
dealing with future pandemics Caitlin
so you replace the Obama playbook with
these two you say the youth development
is it in there that testing needs to
increase as soon as this is happening
and what about personal protective
equipment well personal protective
equipment is very important and I'm
proud of what this administration has
done and I'm very glad that you asked
about that because I have some supply
numbers for you today
I actually shortchanged us a little bit
there ninety two point seven million and
ninety five mass one hundred thirty
three point seven million surgical masks
twenty two point four million surgical
gowns 10.5 million face shields in
almost 1 billion gloves and as you saw
at Owens and minor our domestic
manufacturing has been deployed in this
country in a way it never has been
before since at least world war two and
will become the future playbook I
believe for future administrations and
navigating a pandemic response say no
playbook that personal protective gear
should be increased the production of it
as soon as the pandemic is underway what
it what it says is this that look we
need personal protective equipment and
what did this administration do we gave
it the Obama playbook is on line one of
these I believe is public one is public
so you can look through that online but
what we've done is remarkable and that
is exactly what you just asked me does
it say we need more PPE well we've
delivered historic numbers of PPE 1
billion gloves we'll continue to do that
we'll continue to fill the stockpile
we're ready for the fall and this
administration has acted in a way that I
don't believe certainly based on what I
read in the Obama playbook would have
able to have deployed what this
administration has done Jeff you take so
long to get more masks and swaps and
whatnot which they're still dealing with
now but the other question is on a brick
right the president said yesterday that
he probably should not be working in
federal government any
but he is now expected to start in his
new job next week does the president
still welcome him starting that new
position and can you clarify exactly
what that job is well it's interesting
to ask about whether Rick bright should
start in a position because Rick bright
hasn't showed up for a position he was
transferred to lead a bold new
$1,000,000,000 testing program he's not
yet shown up for work he takes a two
hundred eighty-five thousand dollar
salary that's extraordinary for a
federal government salary and he is
still on taxpayer-funded medical leave
so he can work with partisan attorneys
to malign this president so mr. bright
he should perhaps show up for the job
that he currently has Jeff choose not to
wear a face mask does he think it sends
the wrong message that's his choice you
know he's tested each and every day
those of us around him I'm in the Oval
Office I I wear a face mask on around
him to protect him um he's very
protected he tests negative daily and
that's his personal choice and I would
notice consistent with the CDC
guidelines which say they recommend but
it's the personal choice of the
individual for the American people dr.
burns doctor pouchy today they're both
tested routinely but they both had their
face mask on in the Rose Garden I think
he did set an example he set an example
when he said to the west wing I want all
of you wearing face masks in here and he
noted that I believe it was two days ago
and that is over above and beyond what
CDC guidelines say but all of our
staffers are wearing face masks and that
was at the direction of the president I
think that's a pretty good example yes
I'm gonna ask you about the FDA guidance
the abbot tests but firstly and you know
you talk about all of this preparation
that the Trump administration did but
then how come on January 2020 the
stockpile was as low as it was on
supplies yeah it's a really good
question it's a really important
question perhaps I should redirect your
question to President Obama who left a
stockpile empty and there was a USA
Today fact check of that he left the
cupboards bare as the president noted
and USA Today said there's no indication
that the Obama administration took
significant steps to replenish the
supply of a 95 mass in the strategic
national stockpile after it was depleted
from repeated crises so at the h1n1 it
was full at the end of h1n1 it was empty
and President Obama left it empty and
took president Trump to refill it
national defense five defense strategy
came out in September 2018 and the
president has been now in office for
over three years at this point yeah well
we refilled that stockpile we got the
n95 masks out ventilators another good
example not a single American died for
lack of a ventilator a hundred thousand
ventilators in a hundred days three
times what is produced in the average
year three times the amount of n95
respirators our health care industry
uses we have delivered we cleaned up the
mess that was very clearly left by
President Obama and we got that out and
we Finn and I would also note in terms
of fixing the stockpile it's also fixing
domestic supply chains that was very
important and this president is the
president who took on that issue said we
need to produce here we can't as China
hoards PPE we need to have domestic
manufacturing so there was a systemic
fix that needed to happen and president
Trump is the first president in my
knowledge that has really to this degree
took on that systemic fix the test that
you guys take every day that we've
started been in given
every day and these recent studies
coming out any numbers like a third of
cases maybe missed up to 48 percent of
cases meeting this does that give this
White House any pause are you
considering potentially other tests does
this change the way that you guys are
gonna move you know going forward yes
I'm glad you asked that it's very
important when the FDA gets any
information that calls into question
attached they put it out there it's
incumbent upon them to make sure the
American people have up-to-date
information dr. Han I spoke with him
this morning actually spoke with him
several times he said we continue to
recommend the tests secretary a czar
says we have confidence in the test
otherwise it wouldn't be out on the
market that being said they take any
indication of false negatives very
seriously some of these studies
secretary a czar says he believes there
was user error error in them meaning
that the time transporting them might
have affected the accuracy of the test
but to that end what the FDA has said is
that any negative test results that are
not consistent with the patient's
clinical signs so if you're coughing you
get a negative test it's a nabbit test
you should consider getting a second
test
that's the guidance as of now
he's very frustrated with China and I'll
leave it to the President as to when he
does resume speaking with the Chinese
leader but look China slow-walked this
I've shared with you guys before on
human to human transmission it was
really important that the world knew of
that aspect of the disease but that
information was slow walked through the
w-h-o the genetic sequencing likewise
was not given on until a professor in
Shanghai did so on his own the president
has repeatedly noted that you know why
are they letting flights out of China
but not into China these decisions put
American lives at risk
not just American lives for lives around
the globe we know that this disease came
from China and why that information was
not shared some of the information I
just suggest is really unacceptable so
he's frustrated at this point and I'll
leave it to him talked about having a
warm relationship with President Xi is
that how over is
well I'll leave it to the president
asked how to characterize their
relationship but you know this is a
president who if anyone knows how to
talk to China it's him he did get the
phase one China deal two hundred fifty
billion dollars of purchasing of
American products is a big deal and a
big one for America and it took
president Trump to get that one yes
SuperDuper missile I was asked about
that shortly after the president made
its remarks he declined to combat
referring in fact the White House so I'm
wondering if you can say what the
president was describing yeah I would
just refer you back to the president
mark remarks in the Pentagon I don't
have any new information on that at this
point yes when did the administration
start replenishing the stockpile of PPE
and does that report get into that um
the president immediately when it was
necessary to get more PPE for America's
health care workers immediately went
into action and I've listed out for you
all of the results of those actions
which had been extraordinary mobile
greatest mobilization of the private
sector since World War two and I would
also note I do have some new information
again before January 2024 regarding PPE
and trying to replenish that I I did
talk to secretary azar a little bit
about this yesterday and one of the
things secretary azar said to me is you
know when we got to the federal
government we were on the brink of we
were in very hostile confrontations with
several powers because of the Obama
administration's foreign policy and
there were real bioterrorism threats and
that was the immediate threat that the
administration focused on in terms of
the stockpile and immediately when it
became clear a pandemic was the the
concern over bioterrorism we
transitioned as quickly as humanly
possible and filled the empty cupboards
left by President Obama and I do have if
I can find it in here some new
information on ventilators just to show
how extraordinary this administration's
effort was on the stockpile that we've
shipped 766 ventilators overseas to our
partners because
no one here has died for lack of a
ventilators so we've done so well and
over performed so much we can say that
we've committed over 15,000 ventilators
to 40 countries by the end of July
because that is American ingenuity that
is the government of President Trump and
that is the unprecedented partnership of
this government and the private sector
yes
switching gears for just a moment also
in his interview with Maria Bartiromo
the other day the president suggested
people should be jailed for what he said
earlier in the week was a very obvious
crime you're an attorney and the
president spokesperson perhaps you could
lay out the elements of this crime what
crime was committed and in what way
I assume you're referring to the Obama
administration and the unmasking and
vomiting what is it what are the
elements of that crime yeah I'm really
glad you asked because there hasn't been
a lot of journalistic curiosity on this
front and I'm very glad that you asked
this question
look there were a number of questions
raised by the actions of the Obama
administration the steel dossier funded
by the Democratic National Committee the
opposition political party to the
president was used to attain FISA
warrants to listen in on conversations
of people within the Trump campaign
there was the unmasking the identity of
Michael Flynn and we know that in a
January fifth meeting in the Oval Office
with President Obama Sally Yates from
the Department of Justice learned about
the unmasking not from the Department of
Justice or for the FBI she learned about
it from President Obama and was stunned
and can barely process what she was
hearing at the time because she was
stunned of his knowledge of that we know
that there was a lot of wrongdoing in
the case of Michael Flynn the FBI notes
for instance that said should we get him
to lie as they pontificated their
strategy we know that the identity of
this three decade general was leaked to
the press a criminal leaked to the press
of his identity and violation of his
Fourth Amendment rights these are very
serious questions they've been ignored
by the media for far too long and I'm
very glad that I think that is the
second question that I have fielded on
Lieutenant General Michael Flynn because
justice does matter those questions they
matter
I heard you mentioned one thing you said
was criminal and that was what no the
one thing that I've said that was
criminal the leaking of his name and the
very real questions I've been raised but
if you want to start talking about
wrongdoing the administration happy to
go through Andy McCabe leaking to the
Wall Street Journal and then lying about
it happy to talk about James clapper
lying before Congress saying the NSA
does not monitor phone calls that was an
inaccuracy to say the least if not a lie
and John Brennan telling Congress that
the bogus steel dossier played no role
in the Russia probe when in fact we know
it did and was the basis of attaining
FISA warrants so there's a lot of
mistruths there that were said many of
them under oath so i would point you to
those and the many other real questions
that i hope you all will pursue I never
said that those are your words not mine
but perhaps you should look into it and
give me some answers that is after all
the job that is after all the job of
reporters to answer the very questions
that I've laid out and I hope you guys
will take the time to do it and and I
also find it interesting if we want to
start talking about fabrication of
crimes we can litigate that case pretty
publicly with James clapper who said
what President Trump did with Russia
pales and that Watergate paled in
comparison we can talk about Eric's wall
well lying and saying President Trump
was working on behalf of the Russians we
can talk about Hakeem Jeffries lying and
saying the president was a Russian ask
that we can talk about ships saying
there was ample evidence of collusion in
plain sight when in fact there was not
we can talk about Mark Warner saying
there's enormous amounts of evidence of
collusion we can talk about a CNN
historian who said there was a smell of
treason in the Trump Russia probe when
in fact for three years you all talked
about collusion and there was none and
it was a huge injustice not just to this
administration but to the American
people who deserve truth not the
alleging of absolutely false allegations
against this president yes
[Music]
sorry one second I can't really I'll get
to you next go ahead francis pushback by
a comment by the CEO santa fe that the
united states would be first in line for
a vaccine if that firm develops because
of initial funding by Barda the scene
does the administration think that the
united states should receive the first
dose as a sin if he does discover that
vaccine i don't have I haven't spoken to
the president about that so I don't have
any announcements on that front but yes
back there and then Thank You Kaylee two
brief questions first a follow-up to
Steve's question regarding China 48
hours ago the federal retirement thrift
Investment Board followed the
president's suggestion and cut off any
investment of federal pensions for
civilian and military workers into China
on their markets therefore cutting off
funds that would be invested in
state-run companies will the president
now urge private sector businesses and I
think of Blackrock which is invested in
a hundred and thirty seven Chinese
companies to follow this example and get
out of investing in China well I can't
give any information about what the
president will or will not do next but
it's a really important topic and I
would just say that the president's
decisive move to halt plans for
investing TSP funds into Chinese
companies was the right call it protects
our military federal employees from
risky investments and avoids funding
Chinese defense contractors and this
action halts plans to invest military
Federal Employees Retirement funds of
4.5 billion in Chinese equities so it
was an important move by the president
but in terms of future action on this
front I would leave that to the
president yes other question was in
Turkey recently there's been taught that
president Erdogan would like the
assistance of President Trump with the
currency into
which is in very bad condition will
there be any US support of the Turkish
currency or does he think Vera's otro es
esto tomó populace Oh frosty cuidado de
todo tempo heh trouble Oh trouble
trouble Oprah solution ah pasa por ESO
Murdoch ovitch todo sistema a pasado in
parallel ness periodo Agito cecilia
stodgy municipal opposite process Vika
dodge ability' saudi-led a forum quasi
cuatro mil so SOS a page so desperado
socialist oh man yes occultation momento
de Grenelle decrease among Joe tanto
dues in so much profit
quanto dues equip emergency page Malucci
area maybe 20
[Music]
[Music]
I got started by an Asian on it I would
go to I get stung all the venom on a
milligram per kilogram basis is actually
less toxic than honey developers the
difference is that they have seven times
the volume of as a honey it is in some
Asian cultures considered a delicacy
both the adult and the larva to pupa
people should not panic and I know the
headlines are great but you know we just
need to get a handle on exactly how
extensive this is this is how
maybe 20 or 30 Hornets when they get
into the attack mode maybe 20 or 30
Hornets when they get into the attack
mode or that what has been coined the
slaughter mode will wipe out any colony
of 30 50,000 honeybees within a few
hours I got started by the venom on a
milligram per kilogram basis is actually
less toxic than honey developers the
difference is that they have seven times
the volume in some Asian cultures
considered a delicacy both the adult and
the larva to pupa people should not
panic and I know the headlines are great
but you know we just need to get a
handle on exactly how extensive this is
this is how we feed our family and hair
ills
my husband and I owned a small
restaurant in Chesapeake Virginia yeah
we actually decided to close our dining
room before we got the order from the
governor we have a bunch of friends in
the restaurant industry and one of them
was actually in Italy when everything
started getting really bad there he you
know sent out a text and was basically
like this is coming here how are you
guys going to deal with it how do we get
through this
we've been here for 11 years so we have
a really strong regular customer base
unfortunately most of our business comes
at lunchtime from people who are working
in the businesses around us and they're
all closed right now last I checked we
were down about 70 percent from where we
were this time last year right now there
is no budget at the end of the week we
say here's how much money we have or how
much